[Music]
foreign
there are many sea monsters that are
relatively big but not gigantic yet
there are those which are Kaiju scale in
size but here in this video we will
showcase 10 of them that are comparable
to the Meg so between the sizes of the
Megalodon shark from the first movie and
the larger one to be seen in the second
one so let's get to it
the first one precious from Ice Age this
was a massive whale and its size was
around 30 meters or 100 feet long a bit
bigger than the first Meg which was
around 27 meters or 90 feet long she
could either be an overgrown animated
Leviathan whale or a sperm whale her
enormous stature was undoubtedly her
most distinguishing feature she had him
out which was packed with rows of
massive teeth that was huge enough to
even fit a mammoth she might also
utilize her blowhole to launch water
jets at any potential dangers
the second one the Mayas create from com
Skull Island of 2017. this was a
gigantic cephalopod specimen a large sea
monster that Rivals the first Megalodon
shark in size the Maya squid has a
rounded bulbous head that is somehow
similar in appearance to that of an
octopus rather than a squid it also
possesses countless incredibly long and
thin tentacles the Squid's entire body
is red in color and it can squirt out an
ink that is jet black in color when it
is in stress this cephalopod is 33
meters or 108 feet in length and swims
in the waterways of Skull Island in
search for food which could also include
younger Kongs as well
the third one the akula and his close
cousin denalitza from Avatar 2 the way
of water so they both come in at close
to 40 meters or 131 feet in length the
akula and anulza are predatory fish that
closely resembles the great white sharks
it has a pointed tail that it utilizes
to push itself through the water the air
cooler has a three-part jaw that when
expanded looks like the gaping mouth of
a rattlesnake but split three ways it is
also one of the apex predators on the
planet Pandora's oceans
Number Four The Mysterious color
clawfish from Star Wars The Phantom
Menace this was the second biggest sea
animal that was present in the Deep
oceans of the planet called Naboo the
flat e-like body of the color clawfish
was covered with bioluminescent skin it
was 40 meters or 131 feet long and had a
crocodile-like head and rows of sharp
teeth and a pair of mandibles and his
physique was Serpentine and spine
studded in short they are just terrible
and monstrous creatures
number five the octalis from the movie
Deep Rising as another sea monster that
is gigantic in size but surprisingly
still flexible enough to fit into the
hull of a ship maybe due to its
cephalopod body that possesses no
exoskeleton and therefore can be
squeezed through even small jaws the
octalysis body consists of many long
slimy tentacles with mouse on each one
of them and a body with another bigger
mouth and two big eyes although it
doesn't seem like it the avftalis is in
fact very long around 40 meters a 1 or
31 feet in length
number six the mosasaurus from the
Jurassic World movies this is a beast
among bees A genus of large aquatic
carnivorous lizards from the late
Cretaceous Period in this universe it is
a clone specimen like other dinosaurs
and it can sustain itself in a
near-domen-like state for months without
any food but by the time of dominion the
mosasaurus was bigger than even the
humpback whales like two and a half
times longer as seen in the end scenes
of the last movie if the whales averaged
out at 18 meters or 60 feet long then
the mosasaurus would be around 150 feet
or 45 meters long
the seventh one this Star Wars Universe
Master called the Dinosaur turtle was
seen in the third season of the
Mandalorian it was first seen attacking
a group of Mandalorian younglings that
were training by the edge of a lake then
it was seen a second time devouring a
large predatory Raptor this large
monster possesses the characteristics of
an alligator in its crotch posture limbs
tail and snout but it also had a large
turtle-like shell on his back this
creature is estimated to be around 50
meters or 164 feet long
so these previous entries were all
bigger than a massive Megalodon shot
from the first movie but they are all
still subordinate in size to the Apex
specimen that will be seen in the sequel
this August this Megalodon is estimated
by us to be around 52 to 55 meters or
170 to 180 feet in length and hunts in a
pack of three
now the eighth monster that is similar
in size to the Megalodon is the ravenak
which was the first big creature to be
seen in the series of the Mandalorian
and it was a sea monster that actually
dwelled in another planet called pagadon
it swims beneath the ice sheet and
breaks the barrier in order to attack
unsuspecting prey The Raven ax seems to
look like a cross between a whale a
reptile and a walrus it had two large
dots that protrude down from its upper
jaw and also had a scaly armored skin
its size was estimated to be around 50
to 60 meters or 164 to 197 feet long
with the upper estimate putting it a bit
bigger than a Megalodon shark
the ninth Master okay so we have put
Lizzy again the one from Rampage which
was in another list as well the one that
compared the Meg to even larger sea
monsters and Kaiju but let's see the
mutated crocodile was in fact more of a
similar size rather than a way bigger
monster this crop was 61 meters or 200
feet long and the Megalodon shot was
only just around 6 meters or 20 feet
shorter but the bulk and density of
biomass the Meg could possess as it
lived in the trench might just surpass
the mutated Lizzy in terms of weight
and lastly even the ritosaurus from the
movie the beast from 20 000 fathoms
deserves another spot on this list as it
happens to fall under the same argument
as for Lizzie this underwater dinosaur
that emerged after millions of years was
61 meters or 200 feet long and it
attacked New York City following its
Awakening from suspended animation by
atomic bomb testings in the Arctic Ocean
the ritosaurus was impervious to Small
Arms as its scales were very tough but
sadly larger caliber weapons were used
and was able to kill it in the end
so I hope you have enjoyed watching this
video do hit that like button for
support and subscribe but most of all
smash that Bell icon for regular updates
on new videos right here on this channel
take care fam